great game of the year time it's that
time of year again where we all get to
pick our favorite games and then have
people on the internet tell us we're
wrong and I feel like 2014's probably
got more of that than ever because we
didn't have any like massive standout
fantastic games but we had like two
dozen solid great games so my top five
is super like idiosyncratic and I don't
necessarily think that anyone's going to
agree with it I certainly don't think
anyone's going to have the exact same
five but that kind of represents to me
the really good breath of great games
that we had across a bunch of different
platforms and the variety we had in 2014
at first up this is a new entry because
it just knocked far cry 4 out sorry
about that buddy turns out mario kart 8
is pretty good video game ran this time
last year I was talking hella trash
around the wii u and how it was a total
piece of [ __ ] but it turns out a bunch
of great games came after that system
this year I'm one of them there's my
record eight I've only had the console
for maybe two weeks at this stage but I
played upwards of 15 arrows mario kart 8
it is fantastic doing this sort of solo
trying to win every single tournament
and 50 100 150 is as satisfying as ever
and then also playing with my roomie is
loads of fun you just one of those sort
of one more race type of games there's
this old adage about mario kart where
they say the first my cart you ever
played is the best mario kart you'll
ever play that's total horseshit because
the best mario kart I've ever played is
mario kart 8
my fourth favorite game of 2014 was my
first favorite came of 2013 and turns
out grand theft auto 5 on the
PlayStation 4 is a pretty fantastic
video game not just because obviously
they appraised all visuals and look
super sexy and it's got that much
lighting model obviously first-person
mode is kind of this weird fundamental
change with your relationship with the
world because the I guess intimacy with
the violence and then also because they
remove the protagonist from Fame I've
talked about that on the point that's
really interesting but playing GTA 5 and
first-person on these next-gen systems
actually feels like playing a different
game like it's actually really strange
when you think about one of those first
missions with Lamar when you're stealing
that motorbike I play that you know
probably a half thousand times through
repeating GTA 5 when you play the first
person it actually like feels like a
totally different level I'm I'm not
really sure why it's whatever reason
when you're playing in first person and
because of the like incredible amount of
new detail that they put into the game
not just another operating it but just
like putting [ __ ] in places and then
being able to like see the expressions
on those like Mexican gang members faces
white before you shoot them it just
totally changes like how you approach
the action in that game it's really
strange so I felt when GTA 5 came out on
next-gen that I'm going to be
disappointed that I didn't get to play
GTA 5 for the first time but turns out
playing in the first person actually
feels like playing it for the first time
again
really surprised to say that it's on my
top 10 list for the year that lonely
being number four
you
on the winner of Kings boss game of the
year for 2014 is
so my third favorite game of the year is
gamespot's favorite game of the year I
guess middle-earth shadow of Mordor and
a lots been said about how great an
emesis system is you know had decent the
sort of exploration is how good the
combat is like it's solid mechanics but
for me the reason why that game is so
enjoyable to play for hours and hours
and hours is because it takes the sort
of best element from open-world RPG
games and inserts them into a genre
which as far as I'm concerned has been
pretty boring a bonala for a long long
time like you put it up against another
third person action game like something
like in from the second son like these
games are basically breadcrumb trails
you go into an area you clean up what's
there you go to the next area you do the
missions there and it's all on your
terms you were basically cherry-picking
the sort of types of missions that you
want to do the whole way through it it's
not you know nothing new it's Assassin's
Creed's been doing it forever like even
games like far cry and first person in
there doing it but it's like a massive
trope in third person action games what
Miller does is it takes top control away
from you it's no longer you playing the
game on your terms because the game can
just insert a random element at any time
you may be saying like okay I want to go
to this this outpost and I want to get
rid of all York starer I've got this one
dude over here I really want to kill
then the games like now [ __ ] you I'm
gonna stick this guy over here you've
never met before and also this guy who
tried to kill two hours ago and is now
like super opie and he's gonna mess up
your mission and four third-person
action games that's a fundamental shift
no longer are you playing the game you
want to play at the pace you want to
play it Miller shadow mortar is a game
that's like so confident in what they've
designed that they're like not this is
going to happen and you're gonna [ __ ]
deal with it and that's fantastic
my second favorite game of the year and
I don't think it's appeared on anyone's
lists at all and I'm not surprised but I
had a massive fondness for canon brawl
which is again the sort of mel's one of
my favorite games of all time this worms
this kind of wonderful 2d battling game
with i guess like old-school map
domination stuff like age of empires
you're basically like fighting nai
you're building cannons trying to take
as much as long as possible and there's
a single-player component to it but it's
basically a tutorial to get you to play
online and the online in that game is
absolutely fantastic myself and mary had
a really good game of kind of bra on the
lobby a couple of months ago I when we
have the developers on and I think
that's really emblematic of the sort of
amazing back and forth you can have in
this game it's cutie exterior disguises
an incredibly complex mechanical a game
which involves like so many different
layers of strategy which you can sort of
on earth as you're playing people online
it's a type of game where they teach you
fifty percent of how to play it in the
single-player campaign and then when you
get online you just unearthed all these
amazing different strategies to counter
strategies which account or your
strategy it's an incredibly satisfying
game when you win it doesn't give you
sort of an easy win like a lot of online
games do nowadays and but it's also not
as sort of long and time-consuming as
stuff like dota and starcraft 2 which
were you know require at least an hour
per game you can you can kind of snack
on kind of broad really good and it's
one of those games i don't think many
people have played so chances are on my
top five games you've played at least
four of them i'm guessing yeah but they
kind of also definitely give it a show
and don't get the shield yep the thunder
how do I great make sure that Danielle
somebody and then you can push out over
the money in the little too okay my
favorite game from last year was a GTA 5
and the reasons for that despite of
being a fantastic game were sort of real
personal I was moving over at California
and I don't know what kind of it meant
something to me on a kind of a
fundamental level and my favorite game
this year transistor is very similar to
that I love the games you know aesthetic
the music all that stuff it's a really
enjoyable experience it's also one of
the first games that got me into that I
guess the sort of action role-playing
game genre I will actually didn't really
enjoy bastion much at all I don't tend
to play these types of games so I think
because of that at what this game does
we're probably hit me harder than it
would somebody who's like a real fan of
yachts onra and but outside of that I
come from a computer programming
background and it's sort of design
background and before I did this stuff I
was a web developer when I was a coder
and stuff and that sort of marriage
between art and programming the sort of
marriage of technology and and design
that's fundamentally what that game is
all about and the functions inish the
way you can sort of add them in the
consent amounts of ways like dozens and
dozens of permutations of how you can
set up the transistor and then how that
influences gameplay is incredible and
then on top of that the narrative sort
of weaves around that love of like real
love of coding and real love of design
and ultimately when i was playing this
game it came out right before e3 and
there weren't that many games coming out
and the summer was coming up and you
sort of think in our we're gonna go to
e3 we're gonna cover all this stuff and
then we need to sort of will have that
vacuum period where nothing happens and
i think it hit me at exactly the right
moment because that game is a game about
loving video games it's a game about the
passion of technology and for me
transistor boat and how it's
mechanically set up and how it looks and
how it sounds and in the way it sort of
tells a story that you can pick up on
without necessarily just screaming what
it's trying to say at you for me
it is the perfect embodiment of a game
about the love of video games and that's
why it's my favorite game of 2014
I'm you
we can't